[Musique]
la mort du prince philippe s'est
évidemment une page qui se tourne pour
les anglais officiellement il avait pris
sa retraite depuis quelques années déjà
il ne remplissait plus d'engagement
royaux mais voilà c'était un symbole
pour les britanniques je veux dire la
reine est monté sur le trône en 52 lui
devenu prince consort en 52 et il n'a
pas arrêté d'être d'être dans son ombre
pendant toute l'année c'est un symbole
le prince philip
[Musique]
pour les anglais se sait voilà c'est un
symbole qui s'en va pour la reine ça va
être extrêmement dur je pense parce que
elle elle aussi est à la fin de sa vie
la fin de son règne elle a dit qu'elle
porterait la couronne jusqu'à sa mort
mais voilà elle est lé seul sait c'est
un grand coup la reine de perdre son
mari
à ce moment là c'était déjà le couple en
fait royal qu'on a le plus vus ensemble
elisabeth a le record de longévité de
de règne voilà deux temps sur le trône
d'angleterre et lui avait le record de
longévité du prince consort
tous réunis donc on les a énormément vus
ensemble en fait on les avait vus depuis
le couronnement d'elizabeth et leur
mariage jusqu'à la fin et leurs
centaines d'engagement royaux ensemble
et l'histoire est belle en plus c'est
qu'on sait qu elisabeth ii elle est
tombée folle amoureuse de philippe à
l'âge de 13 ans il y en a 18 et que
quand ils en demandent quand il la
demande en mariage
elle met en avant et on dit qu'elle a
même pas demandé la permission à son
père avant de dire oui et ça a été un
couple très uni alors ils n'ont pas pu
beaucoup profiter de leur liberté
finalement de couple et puisqu'elle a dû
monter sur le trône assez rapidement à
la mort de son père mais mais on dit que
on dit qu'ils se sont toujours soutenu
et que lui à l'ombre d'elisabeth même
s'il avait un tempérament très fougueux
et qu'on sait on connaît ses
frustrations d'être le second est de l
otan l avait le poids du protocole mais
lui encore plus ne pourrait elle ne
pouvant pas prendre la parole mais alors
lui devant marché derrière elle toujours
ne devant jamais s'exprimer de voilette
étant toujours derrière elle
ça n'a pas été facile mais ils ont
toujours ils ont toujours été en tout
cas c'est toujours apparu très très unie
et et en 2011 elle disait encore de
l'usé parole rare de la reine
c'est mon roc qu'il a tout simplement
été ma force démonstrations
[Musique]